what's the closest you guys ever came to
getting uh physically assaulted oh these
two guys did get physically assaulted
we were working at a lot less in midtown
right when these discount superstores
and this big guy twice my size was
shopping for jeans the guys ran down to
the floor like the biggest bra you've
ever seen in your life and they said
myrrh without saying anything run up to
the guy hold the bra up to his chest and
when he asks you what you're doing say
that he's the same size as your wife and
you want to make sure the bra he took
out his cell phone whacked me in the
face gave me a black eye and then chased
me around the store he took three guys
to stop him i eventually ran downstairs
in the basement
behind you guys i was carrying he was
bigger he was like six five six six so
when they find out what it is right do
they have a sense of humor about it or
no he did not he did not
did you guys beef up security after that
no
no not appreciably no i got hit well
that old 70 year old guy that man
strangled me why because i cut him in
line at the tkts booth in times square
for lion king tickets and then he got to
security and when security came over i
said i didn't know what the guy was
talking about and i lied and he just
about had enough of that then he just
grabbed by that he's just not literally
strangling me by the way both whether
it's a six seven big dude or an old man
strangling himself my reaction's the
same either way i'm just cracking up
laughing the whole time danger or not
it's so funny to watch hey i'll take
another call with a guy with a great
question ryan in massachusetts what is
one of your all-time favorite jokes that
you just can't keep watching over and
over again it's a small one but my
favorite joke in the whole history of
the show is is i think it was the two
you were doing the timeshare was it you
and joe doing that yeah and uh they were
selling a timeshare one of the slides
that came up said the alligator that ate
the de luca boy uh has been killed and
and then the next slide says uh he is
now stuffed in the lobby of the hotel
and then the next slide goes the
alligator not the deluca boy
lost it you couldn't even keep going
gotta start going keep it together
i love that joke so much i think that's
gonna be my favorite a long time ago
yeah one that i always heard for the
longest time was we were playing
dentists which is insane to even think
of like we were we were like the three
stooges yeah yeah yeah we were literally
like the dentist like i was in you know
each of us took a turn but people would
come into a dentist's appointment we
presented ourselves as dentists like in
the full garb and everything and uh i
remember that we were in the
state-of-the-art new dentist office and
they briefed us really quickly on the
stuff in the room and the guy's like oh
this is a new chair you hit this button
to bring the chair up down whenever so
the guy came in he lays down he goes i
have a toothache
and i'm like oh wow like like a scale of
one to ten like how bad is he's like no
it's like a ten like even if a little
bit of air gets on it i i'm excruciating
pain i'm like oh let me have a look and
he got in the chair and i i hit the
button and i didn't realize i guess how
high
the chair was able to go up in the hole
and so he went up like like eight nine
it's unreasonable it shouldn't go up
that way it went up like eight feet so i
have this guy levitating eight feet in
the air then i hit the other button and
his head goes down and his feet go up so
he is he's nearly bib is flipping over
he has on sandals his crusty toes are
hanging out
and he's telling me i'm in so much pain
i
i i literally
uncontrollably lost it so bad that i had
to just walk out of the room and like
you know i just i just abandoned the bit
i just walked out because i felt so bad
like cry laughing in front of his face
and then i felt so bad he hurt himself
but like little moments like those like
don't come up hurt himself
his pain was your joy
have you guys had any pranks that you
guys have come up with where uh the
lawyers have said absolutely not
exploit insurance are the people that
that stop us from doing services so
what's it so tell me about the insurance
i love that you know in the joker's
movie that came out about two years ago
our movie i think might have caused
kovit
uh we were only out for like two weeks
in theaters but um at the end of the
movie they made me fly outside of an
airplane like i had to climb out while
the plane was in air onto the wing and
just hold on for dear life as the plane
sped up and did loops and flips and
everything it's a it's a real thing
called wing walking right it's really
really dangerous and the only way the
insurance company uh they took it like a
15 million dollar life insurance policy
out on me and the only way the insurance
company would ensure the movie is if we
filmed that bit on the very last day of
shooting
that way if i died doing it they could
still release the movie